l'aggravation soudaine des escarmouches
dans la zone contestée obligea le
commandant en chef le mystérieux colonel
boumediene que personne ne peut
approcher acheminer rapidement des
troupes au sahara
des troupes seulement car les mig qu'un
dessin ironique a fait offrir par le
maroc à l'algérie indépendante il y a un
an ne peuvent être utilisés le
commandement français de l'aérodrome de
colomb béchar n'a autorisé que les
mouvements d'avions civils
et colomb béchar c'est loin du front
l'avion devra faire encore 700 km en
direction du sud et une fois posé sur la
piste incertaine de tim fouchy les
combattants marcheront 30 à 40
kilomètres avant d'arriver dans la
région des combats
un décor déconcertant pour cette jeune
ou d' on les appelle toujours ainsi
ancien combattant des maquis de montagne
pour la plupart qui sont livrés pour la
première fois un combat face à face un
combat dans le désert l'enjeu de ces
combats un minuscule point d'eau que ne
peuvent même pas utilisé les adversaires
[Musique]
la route de ce qu'il faut bien appeler
le front d'autres la parcours en sens
inverse
pour cela la guerre est terminée
[Musique]
l'adversaire n'a pas seules causes et
ses souffrances
le feu du ciel saharien en chauffant à
rouge les canons d'armes dont ils ne
savent pas toujours très bien servir
actuellement brûlée aux mains de
nombreux combattants pas colomb béchar
encore l'hôpital le plus proche sont
soignés la blesser algérien et
prisonniers marocains
l'un de ceux-ci nous raconte sa guerre
parce que vous avez été blessées suite à
six bandas c'est un territoire algérien
1 ça moi je ne sais pas si c'est un
territoire marocain ou algérien
moi je suis arrivé le jour où on est on
été attaqué le 8 octobre
ce que vous saviez où vous alliez pour
quelle raison on est partis pour monter
la garde comme avant
lorsque moi moi je suis arrivé le jour
et l attaque avant l'attaqué dès 20h45
lors j'ai entendu notre monnaie qui nous
dit il ya un capitaine de l'armée
algérienne qui s'y présenter ou le voir
pour nous dire et tout qu'il sait des
ménages2 est ce que les gradés savez si
c'était eux en territoire algérien ou un
territoire marocain
1 ça je peux pas vous dire je sais pas
sur six avoue s'il sympa
quant aux morts leur nombre est
impossible à connaître au premier tué en
kabylie ou tués à la frontière
alger après des obsèques solennelles
le président ben bella y assister la
population aussi
[Musique]
elle est ainsi prise à témoin de ce que
l'on appelle là-bas les crimes des
impérialistes c'est que pour benbella la
guerre se fait aussi par l'action
psychologique et sur le forum il s'en
prend aux plus proches ministre du roi
hassan ii on ne part pas
[Musique]
la presse s'est aussi mobilisée par
précaution les journaux étrangers
français surtout sont interdits un seul
a trouvé grâce devant les censeurs
algérien pendant ce temps les organes
locaux se déchaîne contre le maroc
entretiennent l'exaltation des
volontaires qui affluent au centre de
recrutement donne de rares nouvelles des
combats et vilipendent la monarchie
marocaine
[Musique]
mais le ton de la presse d'alger n'est
encore rien à côté de celui adopté par
la radio entre deux hymnes militaire la
mobilisation du peuple algérien saura
mettre un terme aux menées impérialistes
des puissances et oddo marocain qui dans
l'inquiétude où ils sont de voir leurs
peuples les renverser n'ont pas hésité à
attaquer l'algérie la monarchie
marocaine n'a plus sa place dans le
concert des nations africaines
elle sait que son pouvoir ne repose que
sur les forces impérialistes les
dirigeants féodaux de rabat reniant les
décisions prises à bandung au caire et
addis abeba font volte-face mettent leur
âme à nu une âme qui n'est pas belle à
voir un jour le maghreb se fera rabat
sera toujours rabat mais les hommes qui
régneront sur la destinée du pays frères
seront issus du peuple du paillon peuple
marocain le maghreb arabe se fera à la
barbe de tous les gros bourgeois
algériens et des féodaux marocain aucun
droit au coeur roitelet aucun oiseau
aucun oisillons de mauvaise augure ne
freinera nos deux peuples dans leur
match vers l'édification d'une société
humaine unis comme les doigts de la main
[Musique]
le climat de la guerre a précipité
l'évolution de l'algérie vers un style
qui fait penser à celui de cuba défilé
volontaires adoption du treillis par
tous les militants et tous les
responsables ministre y compris vendront
les affiches qui rappellent à tous
algériens ou visiteurs les vaudes ordres
permanents de la révolution socialiste
et les slogans anti marocains de
circonstance la capitale cependant
paraît calme paisible
cette impression est elle fondée à
l'université nous sommes allés le
demandé à des étudiants algériens et par
exemple les événements qui se passe en
ce moment on va remonter
quatre courses à force de franchir le
prime de 500 ont pensé que
que vous appelez la nation marocaine est
injustifiée
justifier ou justifier pour nous nous
voyons pas pourquoi
les frontières ont été respectés tant
que la france était avec maintenant ils
nous prennent tindouf
toutes les richesses ou la plupart
richesse ariane sont accusés d'avoir
vendu fin
par exemple je vous apprends rien est ce
que ça vous choque pas un peu et vu
d'autres deux peuples du maghreb
[Musique]
ça chante d'autant plus que c'est des
pays qui soit disant combattu ensemble
pour la liberté
c'est une agression assiste un crime
voyez qu'il reste à faire
aucun on n'en veut pas - enfin en nombre
surtout à la monarchie n'en parle
beaucoup je pense ou et que la
responsabilité ceux du régime et l'autre
s'éduque voyez que c'est plus une
opposition entre par exemple deux
régimes que l'opposition pour
véritablement un tracé de frontières je
pense hui les marocains installés en
algérie ne croit-il pas à cette
distinction entre la monarchie et le
peuple ils se bousculent en tout cas
devant leurs consulats pour obtenir un
rapatriement rapide
ils craignent eux que le conflit dure
longtemps et le président l'algérie lui
que pense-t-il de tout cela nous sommes
naturellement hâlé le lui demander de
nous faire rapidement l'historique des
événements qui ont amené cette
détérioration des rapports entre
l'algérie et le maroc est bien les
historiques je crois que on peut résumer
cela ainsi nous avons appris que le
poste territoire algérien ont été
appelés était occupé à six miles ou à 50
km à l'intérieur du territoire algérien
nos troupes ont intervenu normalement
comme ils font d'ailleurs assez souvent
avec les troupes marocaines est
ordinairement les choses se passent si
l'amicale monde du moins correctement
raccompagne c'est toulouse jusqu'à la
frontière
malheureusement ce jour la stèle n'a pas
été le cas au moment où nos troupes sont
intervenues élus échange de coups de feu
pour nous c'est très simple on a voulu
nous mettre devant le fait accompli et à
la comptine sur le nombre d'avions et de
chars et demain plus là vont pas bien
sûr qu'à nous sommes indépendants depuis
un an nous n'avons pas beaucoup pensé
acheter des avions et des tanks
nous avons pensé à faire autre chose
nous sommes occupés de notre gestion
nous sommes occupés de mener une action
que nous estimons plus valable et
l'action en profondeur tout changer et
structurent notre pays vous des dossiers
le portier un gros free idéologie
également un régime monarchique d'issia
d'elle un régime socialiste
nous pensons que cela aussi entraîner de
compte je vous cite un exemple à la
frontière marocaine et bien prenez la
frontière de ce côté dans ce nouveau
gestion à 500 mètres au delà c'est le
régime du pacha du caïd et ses régimes
du moyen de moyen âge
voilà la réalité et la frontière c'est
tout ne sera peut-être n'existe pas sur
le terre la nature n'a pas créé mondiale
et les hommes juive la nature et donc
c'est une c'était une situation qu'il
pouvait pas ne pas devenir gênant pour
nos amis en face vous recherchez je
crois un arbitrage dans ce conflit
il semble que vous ayez préféré un
arbitrage
du maghreb ou un arbitrage de la ligue
arabe
leye préférait nettement à l'arbitrage
africain l'arbitrage et l'organisation
d'addis-abeba je ne demande pas mieux
nous avons cherché cet arbitrage car
cela correspond à nos options ou notre
option fondamentale est une option
implique un solde extérieur
nous venons de participer à la
conférence d'addis abeba 2
si ni d'accepter la charte d'addis abeba
nous pensons que c'est le cadre naturel
pour résoudre ce problème car il y
associe dire que le problème pose
actuellement elles sont classiques car
des mêmes problèmes existent un peu
partout en afrique
ce problème des frontières nous estimons
que si nous devons accepter un cadeau de
colonialisme mais mauvais cadeau c'est
celui des frontières car si nous
n'acceptions pas cela si par référence à
l'histoire en voulait justifier
l'existence d'un pays on le faisons la
carte de la lune la rencontre touchons à
la géographie en fait au front tels
qu'ils existent actuellement
et bien ce serait un précédent grave
pour tous les pays et notamment pour
trafic et nous voudrions cadre avec
notre problème une fois pour toutes que
ce problème soit l'âge
cependant ce problème la somalie a des
problèmes avec l'ethiopie elle a des
mêmes problèmes que le kenya le toulois
des problèmes
le maroc a des projets que l'algérie
mire les avec la mauritanie les avec le
mali voyez la carte d'arles elle fascine
la cardabelle fasciné bien elle supprime
tout simplement le marais le mari de la
carte de l'afrique
elle va chercher les frontières sud du
maroc est bien à saint louis du sénégal
lorsque l'explosion de reagan a eu lieu
la dernière
le maroc a testé auprès de la france
parce que l'explosion a eu lieu sur son
site et fois et nous a demandé de nous
associer à sa participation tant que
plus important pour vous c'est que ce
problème des frontières avec le maroc et
d'une façon générale l'afrique soit
réglé définitivement et non pas que sa
majesté le roi hassan ii titre le
pouvoir au maroc ce n'est pas ça le plus
important
non nous il prend le ce qui est
important c'est qu'on me fiche la paix
ne peut pas ne pas vous demander ce
présent vous quitter comment vont les
relations avec la france lui
ce programme avec des hauts et des bas
mais ne sont pas vos raisons elle
demeure correcte malgré tout et je dois
dire demeure correct malgré ce qui se
passe actuellement est justement je suis
heureux qu'on va souligner comment nos
relations n'ont absolument aucune façon
at il enfin
obérée par quelque action que ce soit dû
à lens est précisément de violence était
cette épreuve durant des événements qui
sont déroulées sur une tenue qui
continuent à ce d'où ils ouvraient
voulait dire que la france a conservé la
plus grande de 13 ans seulement
vous en êtes content bien sûr il reste
des présidents que en france on ne
comprend pas et vous le savez bien
d'ailleurs toujours que l'on fait ici et
on vous reproche souvent plus que les
mesures de vous prenez la façon dont
vous les prenez ou
trouve certaines expressions certaine
propagande certains gestes de choquant
d'autant plus que le gouvernement
français et le peuple français n'a
jamais manifesté d'hostilité en face de
votre expérience socialiste tout cas je
vis de ceux ci ce que nous n'avons pas
du tout l'intention des pare chocs ont
commencé nous sommes simplement ceci
c'est que chez nous il faut absolument
régler certains problèmes et les régler
rapidement la règle et en fonction d'une
d'une gestation politique qui ce fait
qu'il faut déréglé dans le rang si
quelquefois bien sûr cela peut paraître
choquant de plans des mesures rapides
quand on mange bien qu'on se remplir le
ventre bien on n'est pas pressé ici
beaucoup de gens ont faim beaucoup de
gens des problèmes qui sont posés et qui
voudraient devoir régler et c'est ce qui
explique que très souvent notre action
n'est pas très bien compris
le reste des quatre que j'estime que ce
style de shopping mais je pense qu'on ne
voit pas le tenir compte de cela que
cela est secondaire fou et que ce qui
compte ce sont les intérêts réels
véritable la face non pas les intérêts
privés de telle ou telle mais ben les
intérêts la france et cela
sincèrement nous faisons tout pour qu'il
soit sauvegarde et à nous estimons tous
là on n'est pas seulement d'un tel la
france mais aussi notre intérêt pour
prête des intentions on dit par exemple
on entend dire en france que vous voulez
dénoncer les accords d'evian ou les
nationalisé les pétrole est ce que tout
cela effondrés où elle
je n'ai jamais dénoncer les accords
d'evian j'ai dit que les accords région
ont été conçus dans une dans des
conditions ont-ils fait d'accord
circonstancielle qu'il fallait les
chairs qu'il était sage d'en créer
membres mais il faut reconnaître qu'ils
ont été le produit des circonstances
particulières il fallait faire la paix à
tout prix car il y avait un grave qui
existe dans ce pays il fallait
absolument qu'un accord intervienne et
je personnellement je suis premier à
avoir emporté ma en à quoi cela sert à
ce qui s'est passé mais sinon ça ne veut
pas dire que obligatoirement ces accords
sont ce qu'il ya de mieux pour régir des
rapports de l'acte entre deux pays
il n'est pas question maintenant pour la
seconde question nous est posée n'est
pas question pour nous de le
nationaliser
nous estimons que on l'a fait la portion
congrue à l'algérie est précisément en
raison de ces circonstances
exceptionnelles et nous estimons quand
même que il faut aussi revoir cela n a
pas que sur une percussion de la saison
[Musique]